uh what's your strategy going to have  strategy going into the house is to just  be as fluid and flexible as possible  it's a game of absolute unpredictability  so you could make all the strategies and  plans in the world um but they may not  line up so if you can just adapt in the  moment and try to make decisions that  are going to have the fewest  repercussions in the future that's the  best plan we'll have a showmance that's  a no man's but i do think people  always  forget about friendships having they  always have to be so platonic and all  this other stuff i really do want to go  in that house and love up on everyone um  obviously i will not be making out with  people or having sex with people or  having a relationship existing after  that but yeah going into the house i  still am gonna love up on everyone even  if i'm not gonna end up in a showmance